denn es aus wird ist einer der
vielversprechendsten jungen deutsch
rapper aus hört der arzt verführt den
ehre gebührt kartoffelbrei früher ja und
ich habe viel zeitung gelesen so dass
idioten blatt aber tippen
da stand drin deutschland hat probleme
mit hass rappern und ich habe gedacht
wow so schlimm so nah
ich will auch unbedingt als rapper
werden soll weil ich bringe ja alles
übertrieben mit guck mal ich hab fast
hauptschulabschluss ich sehe übertrieben
reich aus sonne ich sehe gut aus und ich
habe vor den hass ja sonne aber dann
haben die autos von der berufsschule
gesagt dass rapper angeblich kein
lehrberuf wäre die wochen sind die
könglichen schreiben kann das sein
die wollen mein traum zerstören aber
niemand kann meint raum aufhalten
was brauchst du [ __ ] ich fertig but
what do schnappe ich werd ich meine man
das heißt schlappe ich hab eingekehrt
du denkst du dass den himmel ich zeig
dir beide tschuldigung schaffen
gesprochen
es ist dennis erster tag als rapper aber
schnell hat er sich in die materie
eingearbeitet
heute dreht denn es sein erstes echtes
rap video ja dass mein manager der tarek
und soja und er meint auch der hat noch
nie so viel talent auf einem haufen
gesehen weil ich mein ich feiere das so
übertrieben ab mit meinem video so weißt
du eigentlich sportlich sohn lamborghini
nutella oder wie das heißt ja jetzt hat
der tarif nissan micra besorgt sondern
das wird der phasenweise tendenziell in
dieselbe richtung buttermilch also erste
szene fünf tätowierte [ __ ] räkeln
sich auf dem lamborghini ich meinen
micra aktion ja jetzt habe ich gerade
gehört dass das mit dem beach es nicht
funktionieren tut wegen metro oder wie
das heißt und so stattdessen haben wir
jetzt eine alleinerziehende berufstätige
mutter
aber geht ja auch irgendwo in dieselbe
richtung
in seinem ersten rap versucht dennis
aussucht das unmögliche er will alle
religionen auf einmal beleidigen jesus
video das ich euro und mohammed dem
propheten den der pflicht nicht mehr mit
sagen willst du privat wurden alle
umbringen werde na gut ich bin dann lief
er millionär hat patrick punkte bieten
und coole konnte und sagen hey man kann
nicht mal in deiner vanille mit winkeln
dann wünsche ich auch vorher kaum lassen
zu aral geht und martin kemp damen und
herren